hello everyone thank you for coming back
for this panel it is my great honor to
introduce our next fireside chat for
today incredibly excited to have both
Eric Schmidt and Shahnaz Davor here
tonight today for a next fireside chat
they both probably don't need that much
introduction but just in case eric is
technical advisor at alphabet and was
CEO at Google between the years of 2001
to 2011 where he led them from being a
start-up to the bear moth and the
amazing tech company that they are today
and Shahnaz diver's executive advisor at
Google Ventures
she has advised companies such as
Netflix Walmart Polyvore Baidu Khan
Academy Zynga and most recently with CMO
at Udacity
please help join me in welcoming
Shauna's and Eric to the stage
[Applause]
[Music]
well guys how was the morning good what
was the most inspirational speech this
morning there you go okay Eric and I are
gonna kill it today just like you know
okay guys we've been doing this together
for 25 years few people know that I
actually started my career working with
Eric and that is true but Eric nice
socks today what they matched your
outfit okay here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna change this differently
because we had to pull you guys all out
of your breakout session and taking your
photos and getting made-up
we're gonna go for 45 minutes and Eric
loves to take Q&A so we're gonna open it
up for at least 20 minutes of Q&A so
I'll start with some prepared questions
and then we'll take it from there so
just get ready with any question under
the Sun that you want to ask Eric okay
so first of all I wanted to just ask you
Eric you really personify lifelong
learning you were at Google as the CEO
for yours
you built an iconic company in Sun then
you were the chairman of alphabet you
could do anything you wanted in the
world and you decided to go back to
lifelong learning and are now an MIT
fellow tell us why and how that decision
came about well first place thank you
guys for having me I'm here because I
think Udacity represents one of the
great new innovations in learning of all
kinds and I'm extremely worried that the
R&D component of learning the R&D
budgets at the federal and state level
even within universities are very very
low so everything that we can do to get
venture money foundation money into
learning how to learn and new ways using
new technologies is what I want to be
associated with in my case the way I
think about it is I was a programmer for
about 14 years and then at Sun and
Novell I was there for about 18 years at
Google a CEO and chairman 17 years what
do you want to do next and I'm still a
Google employee and I'm still on the
board next 15 years what I really want
to do is work on the applications of the
kind of technologies that Udacity
teaches to make the world a better place
right an obvious one is learning but
it's also other things there plenty of
uses for AI and machine learning that
are really profound so you touched on AI
a little bit and today he dasa d
announced their school of AI with three
new nano degrees congratulations well we
can congratulate Sebastian wherever
years in the audience but one of the
things that people constantly talk about
AI is the impact it's going to have and
people feel it's gonna hurt us and some
people feel it's gonna be amazing where
do you stand on that because there are a
lot of people I think I think it's very
clear that AI and machine learning are
really good for pretty much everything
and I'll give you a sort of
straightforward argument what the deep
learning stuff that you're seeing using
today is really sophisticated pattern
matching and there's a great deal of
evidence that things which humans do
they're very repetitive and very boring
can be replaced by things which are more
automatic this by the way is automation
it's been true in manufacturing for a
long time so we believe that this will
free up people to use their brains and
higher-order functions and the obvious
question there is what happens to jobs
and people always say well there's gonna
be this job loss but what you miss when
that happens is you don't can't name all
the new jobs that come because of
greater efficiency greater globalization
and so forth so there's no question
there's an effect but especially using
Udacity z' AI learning modules and so
forth I think people will do well
overall Society will be much better and
much stronger simplest way to think
about that is look as the gains that AI
machine learning have been applying to
translation google translate or health
right we have all sorts of interesting
new results in health where because our
biology and we as humans are pretty much
all the same really makes a difference
what are some of the applications you
see that are going to benefit society
with AI well there's been of course a
lot of discussion here with self-driving
cars
sebastien of course is a true hero of
the of the country in the world for what
he did to get that started when he was
at Stanford way back when and getting
our program started so I think that
self-driving cars will ultimately were
result in a very large reduction in
deaths on highways for many many reasons
starting with the fact that the cars can
see 24 hours a day and computer vision
is now generally better than human
vision right so as a general rule if
you're confused by this think anything
that involves human vision human acuity
is probably better done by a computer
advising the human because computer
doesn't get tired vision doesn't get
blurred that kind of stuff and driving
is an obvious one
anything where they go to you go to the
doctor the doctor sort of pokes around
and looks at you and so forth and so on
I'd much rather have the dermatologist
take a picture of my skin get it
classified by a very well-trained
classifier and then discuss with me what
the classifier says right another way of
making and by the way the dermatologist
doesn't go away right the dermatologist
gets more efficient and more accurate
which is in my interest as his or her
patient makes sense
do you see AI doing a whole lot in life
sciences since you just talked about it
it seems it seems that there are it's a
target-rich environment and life
sciences like we've never seen before if
you look at genetics we don't really
understand the things that cause gene
expression in the ways that they do and
there are many many research projects
which do roughly the following they
measure the system which of course
varies a great deal and then using
machine learning they can predict its
outcome from a scientific perspective in
genetics that's a huge change because
now they have a machine that can predict
what will happen when they perturb the
system that's how they do their science
in drug discovery it turns out my simple
model of a chemist is the chemist gets
up in the morning has a great idea he or
she goes to the lab tries the idea out
in the afternoon by the evening it
doesn't work they go home go you know
have dinner go to sleep have a new idea
the next morning can we automate that
and it looks like in for example
chemistry and biology we can understand
the the ways in which the molecules
attract and bind to each other and we
can run many many parallel simulations
to see this many people believe that the
results that we saw with alphas alpha go
in the Nala's Eero where we were able to
learn essentially to optimize a very
complicated treat research game which
that would
is will apply to that kind of problem
that's a big breakthrough what does it
mean for you better drugs faster drugs
faster drug discovery lower cost of
drugs right you you know what do we care
about this of course we do and then if
you look in the clinical area when you
go to the hospital you think of yourself
as a unique person and you are what you
forget is that there are thousand people
who you don't know who are medically
identical to you
wouldn't it be nice there they're
medically identical they're not the same
as you they don't think the way you do
and so ever but they're medically
identical they have the same list of
problems and good things and bad things
and so forth wouldn't it be better if
the doctor had in front of him or his or
her computer an analysis of the other
999 with their outcomes right and the
computer do a prediction one of the
rules about artificial intelligence is
that the classification that I'm talking
about is very good but it's prediction
is much more valuable so the ability to
predict what's going to happen next gets
really really interesting in something
like medicine that's cool you talked
about self-driving cars we also have an
Anna period Udacity and flying car
program and Sebastian just kind of
announced his whole thing with kitty
hawk can you give us your thoughts on
that and where you see that going well a
long time ago Sebastian and I sat down
and I said what is the future hold right
and he started talking about really the
things that are going to be required to
change transportation and so the core
argument is that there is the third
dimension that it's not being used and I
think Kitty Hawk is is a first example
of what will become a very large market
I think it's important to remember if
you go back to self-driving cars the
original funding and work was done in
the 1990s the DARPA challenge so 2004
2005 now it's 2018 or so they're driving
around in Arizona right most of you did
not arrive here in a self-driving car
you could see one outside these things
take much longer than you think on the
other hand if you talk to people in the
early 2000s who were visionaries they
would say well of course cars will be
driving me self-driving but they
couldn't necessarily have described the
algorithms because the algorithms that
need that were needed to do to be able
to do self-driving cars in the way we do
it today were discovered in the form of
deep learning in the early to
thousands so one of the things about
science that about innovation is that
sometimes ideas sit around for a while
and they're clearly correct but they're
waiting for a breakthrough and when the
breakthrough happens boom it all happens
and that's the magic of Silicon Valley
that's the magic of the American
entrepreneurial system that's the magic
that's the magic of how venture
capitalists work it's the magic of
actually sitting in this room it's the
Computer History Museum and the Computer
History Museum is nothing but about that
you have been a coder for 14 years I
think few people know that that you just
talked about it
but I don't think you code anymore no I
wrote a program called Lex which is
still in use at Google okay it's
disturbing that they're still using a
program that I wrote 41 years ago do you
think we should offer a nano degree
endorsed by Eric Schmidt I unfortunately
they will come up and file bug reports
and I don't but in all seriousness you
have talked about the fact that you're
really good at seeing what's out there
and you tend to have been that
historically and good at predicting you
helped Google get into the mobile space
in fact few people know that when Eric
was at Sun he actually drew a diagram of
what the world would look like 20 years
from there and actually drew a cloud and
basically said we would have a cloud and
all the services would come out of it
I'm not really sure how he thought of
that by the way you made me sign it I
did make you sighs David Haye 25th 1995
just pretty much 23 years ago so if you
look out five two just just just to sort
of hammer on it basically you had a
handheld IP device which is also known
as a phone and then you had
general-purpose computing and then you
have a receiver with cloud services
right on this and today of course that's
the most exciting thing going on in the
enterprise side of computing so where do
you see if I asked you to draw one today
what would it be like well I think you
could want to talk about the short term
in the longer term so I think for the
short term which is sort of five plus
years the architecture that is cloud
computing fast networks and Android and
iOS devices and by the way
in that order Android and iOS do the
math guy that architecture is is correct
and the games that we're gonna see by
having a small number of programmers who
can take the data that they can get from
the client-side put it through these
fast networks and used machine learning
and I just gave you the healthcare
examples but you can imagine apply this
to supply chain management to learning
about how people communicate with each
other there are many sociological and
historical analyses that are now
possible because of the kind of Big Data
revolution I think that will be the
center of the design virtually all of
the deep learning is essentially this
powerful pattern-matching technology
that I'm describing essentially starts
with vision and moves on I think that
that's sort of the next five to ten
years there's simply too much money too
much investment too many people to think
that that will go somewhere other than
what I just described the question is
what happens after that
and I don't think we know it's pretty
clear that the world will still be phone
based because phones are so powerful now
look at the addiction people have to
their phones people you know touch their
phones 1200 times a day people you know
50 years ago used to smoke now they just
hold their phones and it's the same
phenomenon less carcinogenic it's a good
thing so I think it's a fair statement
that phones will be the basis for it and
I think it's reasonable to expect that
the UI and the way you interact with the
phone will change because of gains in AI
and so without knowing what it will look
like it's fair to say that they that
with your permission and all of that the
phone will become even more personal we
are working we're Google are working
incredibly hard to bring out a vision
that we call the assistant which is an
assistant that again with your
permission and your opt-in really helps
you get through the day make suggestions
and so forth and you can imagine the AI
technology getting better and better and
better at that and furthermore since
there are commonalities between how
people operate I can say well what
should I do
I'm bored tonight what should I do and
the computer can say well everybody you
know is going to the movies because they
all want to go see the road one movie
all right that sort of useful
information right is it really going to
be controlled more by voice and speech
most people believe that well I should
say that that 10 years ago if you'd
asked me that what we're talking about a
I would occur and that the voice
revolution would occur I would have said
not ready right because for my whole
computer science career which is more
than 40 years a voice and AI and so
forth were were hopeful so a series of
breakthroughs which started with the
learning and and some new techniques in
the speech area have allowed us to to do
extraordinary things with voice so I
think it's reasonable to expect that at
least for many for many industries the
primary input will shift from typing to
voice command especially for people who
are doing things with their hands right
so the most obvious is the doctor so you
go to the doctor again going back to the
AI theme what do they do they look at
you they poke around and then they spend
a lot of time typing in some 1980s
terminal right filling out a form that
they complained about if you ask them so
why is that not done automatically for
them why does the computer not listen to
the conversation I spoke at a conference
called hymns and talked about the idea
that maybe in ten years you'd have a
doctor/patient conversation again this
is speculation but it's the industry
might get there a lot of players have to
make this happen where I name this
product Liz after the first female
doctor in our country which was 18-49
Liz Blackburn and Elizabeth Blackburn
and she but anyway imagine a microphone
and a speaker and a headset and there's
a consultation right the patient says
you know my foot hurts and you know the
doctor says we already treated that and
so forth and so on and then the headset
is feeding information to the doctor of
the computers analysis of what's going
on and after some agreement they decide
on the treatment
and the notes are written up the
conversation is transcribed for other
doctors to view right again all is part
of the EHR under HIPAA compliance think
about the value of that we think about
the global implications because we have
a lot of people on the livestream
different areas could be enormous - yeah
one of the one of the things that
medical care is that in in here in
Silicon Valley we tend to take for
granted the the benefits of first world
first world connectivity for ask world
systems and so forth the vast majority
of people in our world do not live in
such a society and so the general theme
of telemedicine which is not unlike the
kind of deep learning that that that you
all do teaching of is very very powerful
in terms of getting that information out
to the doctors who may not have
textbooks I'll never forget I was in
Kenya and I have a friend there and I
was saying I was so happy to have Google
and I said why do you have Google you
know I mean it's pretty nice to have
Google but why are you so happy said
well we don't have any textbooks I said
you're a professor of computer science
and you teach PhDs yeah we don't have
any textbooks at our University it's the
top university in Kenya so all of a
sudden they went from you know
scrounging around a few textbooks and
sharing them to having access to all the
world's information for some super smart
graduate students right the same thing
can be applied to again using medicine
as an example when you go back to the
original distance learning right that
the Udacity is the third or fourth
invocation and people were always struck
by the fact that they would have fifteen
twenty thirty thousand students and then
they would do the math and they were
discover that 90% of them were outside
of the United States well guess what do
the math of the world's population right
again we're so we're so narrowly focused
on our own sensitivity and these again
foreign students are incredibly highly
motivated right because for them this
education is a ticket out of whatever
problem they've got in their society
gives them enormous enormous status
which is why I think the micro degrees
that you do
so important and recently Dusty's
figured I would do group group projects
right so here's another example where
the typical typical knock on these
things was that this kind of distance
learning was individual but we all know
that people learn in groups well now you
all right by virtue of innovation have
come up with a way of solving that this
is what I'm talking about we need to
have lots of those kinds of ideas and
lots of companies like Udacity I'm gonna
switch gears for a second you've had an
amazing career you still do 40 years of
being in the business what are one or
two things that totally surprised you
well almost everything surprised me I
talked a great deal about power laws and
network effects but when presented with
one I'm always surprised and you think
I've seen this movie enough times that I
would say oh yeah I saw that before but
I think there's something about all of
us where we assume a static environment
around us when in fact the world has
changed very quickly so for the last 15
years I've talked a lot about the power
of the Internet and I'm very proud to
have been associated with the spread of
the Internet many of the things that
have occurred as a result of the
internet I did not foresee and would not
have predicted right the most than the
most negative example being nation state
interference in other countries over the
Internet
right but I also managed to forget that
there would be things like uber right
and lyft and those kinds of things if
you look at my predictions I was very
good at saying there will be a device it
will have a map it will know where it is
but I didn't finish the sentence so my
advice to you all is finish the sentence
all right so I just said you got this
revolution in cloud computing and AI and
so forth it allow us all to use big data
to now finish the sentence and that
becomes the startup that you should
found or the company that you should
join if you were to learn one new
subject today what would it be
almost certainly genetics so in my
limited understanding of other fields
the geneticists and the problems that
they're dealing with are so profoundly
interesting the way I was not
particularly interested in medicine
because it was sort of squishy I don't
like I liked electrical or
you know my house as opposed to plumbing
because the plumbing was kind of squishy
and and I didn't really like biology
because he was squishy so sorry
so the biologists have figured a way to
go from squishy to digital which is
something I understand very well and the
neat thing about biology today and
genetics is it they get into the digital
incredibly quickly in which case it
becomes a very very powerful
computational tool and the kind of thing
that they're doing with genetics in
terms of understanding human evolution
our susceptibility to disease are
dealing with rare genetic disorders this
kind of things are profound are there
some things you've seen in genetics that
have surprised you recently of where it
could go the thing I'm most surprised
about science and genetics in general is
how much harder life is than the digital
world I live in so the way you you have
fun if we're biologists Genesis is you
say well like why don't we have a
digital model of a cell and then they
get this long sigh right because if you
can't digitally model a cell it's very
hard to imagine doing many of the things
that I would like to do in biology right
the cell is the basic unit of biology we
all understand it's really important but
that's the level of understanding these
are the smartest people in the world and
they can't answer that question that's a
very high priority they're working very
hard on it what I'm gonna do is now open
it up to questions and then I'm gonna
ask Eric one last questions so I think
we have mics in the audience with Alanna
so if you could just if you don't mind
you're stating your name and maybe if
you're a student to be Audacity what
nano degree are taking so Eric could
answer the questions hi my name is
Gonzalo la Torre and I'm an alumni from
the digital marketing nano degree and
for my benefit how long did the named
degree take it felt like a lot cuz I had
two small children but it I think it was
like two two months it was really nice
to just be really one of the piano it
was kind of bigger than Nano it filled
the macro nano
a new product from Udacity first off
thank you for your book it made me
change the way I see management and how
much is Google allocating to mental
health we actually have a large group
now working on employee happiness one of
the most interesting things we
discovered is that our employees are not
taking their vacations so we put in a
program where we told them that they had
to take their vacations and they had to
stop working because we measured and
their productivity was better when they
actually took a vacation and came back
refreshed but they were so driven or so
worried or so crazy or whatever that
they weren't doing it there are many
many examples of those kinds of
interventions that we've been trying to
do you know Silicon Valley's pretty high
pressure place and a lot of that
pressure comes maybe the people started
off being kind of high pressure anyway
I'm pretty intense anyway and so we're
working on it oh hi hi so my name is
Sean and I just finished the artificial
intelligence nano degree and I'm
currently a PhD student in neuroscience
and biology antastic so you can answer
all the questions so I should mention by
the way the neuroscience is one of the
most interesting areas same because of
this ability to go from the squishy to
the anta to the dis re to the to the
digital world and yet a lot of people
who believe that we can get tremendous
insights in the brain because of the
work that you're doing
Thanks well I guess my question is what
do you think or how do you suggest we
try to almost Paiva ties and encourage
scientific research particularly in the
neuroscience and biological space
because as a PhD student I've actually
observed a lot of my peers myself
included being compelled to essentially
leave because funding is a real issue
across the u.s. so I'm not sure I
completely agree with the premise that
it should be privatized I think the
university system of the United States
is the strongest in the world you know
18 of the top 20 universities are in the
world are us-based that kind of thing
and I think it's product
impact are without question in the last
few decades our federal government its
infinite wisdom has not been growing
research funding and in the mental
health and in general and NIH and Health
Sciences between 2008 and 2016 there was
a 30% absolute cut in funding which is
inconceivable I mean here you have this
incredible increase in the number of
older people and you're cutting the very
funding that will enable the kind of
drugs to have them have a healthier and
better life right so the recent bill
that was assigned does in fact include
increases in funding of the things that
we're talking about but it's still too
little especially when you think about
we're going into the information age so
I think the first message is that the
majority of the funding that of stuff
that you and I care about is not going
to come from companies or individuals
it's going to come from governments
around the world I will also tell you if
it's easier to motivate you by a threat
about China the China doesn't have this
confusion and China is investing massive
amounts of money in R&D which will
benefit us but will primarily benefit
Chinese companies and competitors and
those sorts of things so whether you
view it as a challenge from China who
get it or our opportunity to lose the
leadership we need to increase federal
support I've written about this quite
extensively in neuroscience in biology
there are quite a few sort of
pharmaceutical models where basically a
firm will do a partnership with up with
a university and then the firm will get
the bit will fund the research we get
the benefit of the research I'm ok with
that as long as the majority of the
research is in the open it's very
important that the kind of stuff that
we're talking about here be open source
to the reap ossible published in the
open because that's how our research
enterprise works you don't host you
don't keep your results to yourself you
share them you get the credit but you
share them so other people can stand on
your you know shoulders and that's how
my career was built and I know that I'm
still when I started I was standing on
the incredible work of people 5 and 10
years older than I next question
I think Alana has the mic somewhere so
do we have another mic yes yeah my
career go ahead thank you very much sir
um oh sorry about that my question was
you were talking about squishies certain
industries are being squishy and
becoming digitalized
do you see any other sectors of the
economy of sectors a science that if
right now currently being squishy
if digitalized might be a huge place for
all of us maybe - and of course my
Squishy comment was a joke
so please please do not be offended it
was just it was good it was easy for you
and very hard for me to do that side I
was much better on the digital side
pretty much everything seems to be
reducible to a digital understanding if
you instrument it well enough so if you
look at physics and chemistry and you
know the really really hardcore science
stuff most people I've talked with have
a way of monitoring or measuring
something to observe what's going on and
then they can use the tools that I'm
describing to build systems that mimic
it alter it
challenge it right or predict its future
outcome there are people who believe
that the next generation of quantum
computers which appear to be operating
under real quantum effects can be used
to not simulate but actually show real
life biology real life physics so one of
the interesting applications at a
research level of quantum computers is
it's the first digital device that
actually behaves exactly like an analog
world because the whole the real world
the world we live in today is
fundamentally all quantum computing so
it's a very interesting idea I will see
if it works or not
next question oh yeah thanks you think
you will for being here my name is Derek
I'm from Minnesota I completed the
front-end degree and then also I'm in
traditional school for pharmacy so I'll
be a pharmacist in a month that Greg
what does front-end mean Oh front-end
web development nano degree okay so
you're a pharmacist who can write do web
working on it I guess my question is
perhaps for both of you
what's an opinion or a perspective that
you held either on I guess leadership or
technology or anything that recently or
sometime in your career
stands out to you that you've changed
your mind on us so I think one of the
things that you'd asked me started the
day with is the fact that change is
constant and what has surprised me
overall in actually just looking at this
generation is lifelong learning
continuous way past school so we were
always under the impression that we went
to finished undergrad at 22 if you
decide to get a PhD it was 28 but we're
living longer so our average lifespan is
80 which means you're gonna spend at
least 50 years working and the fact that
we believed or still continue to believe
that what we learn 2:22 would be valid
when were 62 I think that had to get
thrown out of the window I think that
was probably one of the big kind of
changes that I had to make in my
thinking and just looking at things
overall and I have three kids and I
fully believe that they will continue to
be learning way past school two of them
are in college and none of them believe
they're gonna be done after college they
actually have a mentality that says I
have to keep learning so I think that's
one of the things for me right you know
the world the world today is infinitely
more complicated than it was when I was
your age and it seems infinitely
complicated at the time so we seem to
have an enormous ability as humans to
build these complex sort of knowledge
systems right the culture so think about
how much you know now as an adult in
addition to pharmaceuticals and web
programming just all of the conventional
knowledge you have about life because
you're surrounded by information I'm
very happy that Google and I personally
participated in making that happen
I guess the surprise has been that the
systems of the world and humans in
general have not adapted as quickly to
it right new ideas come out but people
don't learn them as quickly or society
doesn't change governments are very very
change averse
that's a constant surprise to me and
maybe that's always been true hi my name
is Andres I'm from Colombia and I took
intro to programming and my question is
what do you think is going to happen
with quantum computing and quantum
machine learning so so a good question
we we don't know there are a number of
companies Google being one IBM being
another a few others that are working on
increasing the number of qubits which
are quantum computing bits we recently
announced that we had gotten to a number
higher than 50 IBM announced that we
gotten to 50 you know it's very
competitive in the research sensitive
competition there's a series of
algorithms that are very that are
quantum super supreme in the sense that
they are very very long in traditional
computing longer than our lifetimes and
very short with a quantum computer so
when we can show that that's true I
think there will be an explosion in
people who are trying to come up with
algorithms that fit that quantum
paradigm and the most obvious one will
be prime factoring although most people
think that prime factoring will is a
long number of years off for all sorts
of technical reasons so I think that the
the steps will be we'll get to quantum
supremacy at some point don't a win when
that happens there'll be an enormous
attempt at trying to fit every hard
np-hard problem essentially into a
quantum factorable problem see how that
goes and that will then lead to another
round of scientific discoveries hi my
name is I'm just graduated high school
from Auckland New Zealand
I was just wondering what interpersonal
skills or values do you think have
served you most throughout your career
especially early on well so when I was
in if I try to remember what my life was
like back then
I I was a person who talked all the time
I was I would chat with everyone and I
was completely open and didn't have a
lot of sophistication as to who I was
talking with so if you came by my room I
would talk to you until you got tired of
talking to me
and so I think in my case the thing that
is true about me as opposed to many
other people is I was always surrounded
by people and I was always talking to
them now maybe half of what I said was
was terrible but I was communicating
invite and I learned by talking and
today I noticed the way I learn is by
giving a speech not from giving the
speech but perfect perfect but preparing
for it so I think people learn in
different ways and for me if Shahnaz
tells me something I'm much more likely
to put it in my brain and if I read it
all right so if you're one of those
kinds of people then develop your
interpersonal skills by asking questions
remember that you're not learning
anything when you're talking okay I know
this is a shock okay furthermore you
have two ears and one mouth use them in
that proportion it'll be fine
so I have this rule very often when you
people come into companies I tell them
to keep quiet for the first two weeks
because chances are they probably don't
know what they're talking about and they
might as well listen so it's one way to
look at it - I don't think I'd be able
to do that please
good rule Eric's the exception I'm NASA
I'm a recent graduate from a
self-driving car nano degree I guess the
question always amazed me is how we're
gonna preserve our data for future
generations because right now we have
zero one machines and we gotta have
quantum machines
how we gonna preserve the data we have
our photos our documents for our many
many generations ahead if I were you I'd
store them in Google
[Laughter]
the serious and that was a serious
answer but this the serious answer is
there's a lot of people who are looking
at data formats from the 1950s and 1960s
and 1970s I wish there were many and
trying to make sure that the encoding
and representation of that data is
understood so it can be transferred to a
modern digital service my own view of
this is that if you think about the the
modern platforms that we all use today
you know Facebook Twitter Apple Google
and so forth these companies are not
going to go away and the data that's on
all those pictures that you took they're
going to be moved forward and even if
the companies don't survive which I
think they will there will be successors
and there's value in that data so I'm
not as worried about this for current
information I think the current
standards are going to be preserved
because there's a business logic around
it I do think the historical stuff needs
some special attention hi my name is
Derek and I'm participating in the grow
with Google Scholarship challenge for
the mobile web specialist so thank you
very much for good mr. cook from Intuit
told us a little bit earlier today that
he and bridges is the future of turbo
taxes to include essentially having an
AI that can ask you for permission and
then go collect the data it needs for
you to file your taxes I I imagine that
might include you know accessing
information stored in the cloud okay
what is Google working on through
machine learning and AI to provide a
model that helps to protect the end-user
when it comes to AI and such that have
the ability to go out and gather
information from around the cloud so so
the first place is that we work really
really hard to keep your data secure and
so he just has a pause if you all are
not using two-factor authentication you
need to stop this meeting and go use it
and you know what I'm talking about
right if you're not using Chrome you
should switch to Chrome
and if you're not using Gmail you should
switch to Gmail and let me observe that
all three of these things are free so we
don't make any money from that but they
are by far the most powerful platforms
for doing for doing that and then you'll
get the protection a lot of the
protection you'll get by using
two-factor Plus chrome plus Gmail to
answer your question more directly our
platforms allow the application to do a
great deal of encryption and security
ultimately the security of your data is
a function of the quality of the
application in our case the applications
that you see on Google we work really
hard to keep to keep to keep encrypted
I'm sure that when Intuit does the same
kind of thing on the cloud they'll want
to have the same kind of powerful tools
for the same reason hi ma month very
simple question for you what is the
future of humanity in your view given
the current environment we live in where
do you see the general question is the
future of humanity going forward and I
think it's good what happens is that
everybody reads the news and decides
that the world is going to fall apart
but scientists and engineers have
measured all of this and a child born
today has the highest likelihood of
reaching his or her natural lifespan
which in many developed countries is up
to a hundred years than ever before the
plagues that affected young men and
women of fifty years ago 100 years ago
200 years ago are largely under control
there are new problems but
mathematically you would always choose
to be born today than yesterday or the
day before and so when I think about the
world going forward I think the biggest
problem in the world going forward will
be a lack of population because our
population globally is going to increase
to something like nine nine and a half
billion and it's going to start
declining it's already declining in many
Eastern European countries it will start
declining in my life
time in the United States it will start
declining in my lifetime in China right
and so forth
so the issue in 50 years will not be to
much population but not enough
population growth where education will
become even more important because we
need these people to be more productive
I'm also not so my core argument here is
optimistic I think there are many many
challenges looking at this audience none
of you did the duck-and-cover drills
that I did when I was six years old
right so people forget you know the
Soviet Union versus the United States in
1963 and the Cuban Missile Crisis we've
been through these things before and
human sanity right reasonable behavior
ultimately came through the stakes are
very high but I think will do very well
hi my name is Tamra Williams and Eric I
have a question um can you share with us
one of your greatest disappointments
that you've seen in the industry and
whether that experience has anchored
some of your greatest achievements well
I've made many mistakes so as an
executive on the other hand there were
some successes too so when I think about
the way we use computers today there are
two comments they've always been too
complicated and they're still too
complicated and the other observation is
the teams of programmers are too large
so if you go to any company in our
industry they'll have a hundred people
doing this and 200 people doing this and
300 people doing like like this they're
incredibly productive given their size
but when I was a programmer the idea
ideal term you know team was like two or
three or the number of people you get
around the table that have pizza right
and that's how you build software mm-hmm
so I worry that there's an because of
the slowing of Moore's law and the
incredible complexity that is required
to build these powerful systems that
we're going to see a loss of
productivity because of the combination
of those two Moore's law is not is it's
not completely dead but it's slow to a
great deal and in our industry that most
of the effort and
is now on specialized AI processing
units we call our STP use which have
been very successful so that's been
helping us but the physics are the
physics and I do worry about the size of
the teams and I see this in every
company not just not just in Google
hello and my name is Kostas dammit eNOS
and thank you for coming and giving us
your information but you were talking
earlier about AI and I was wondering us
as humans our hardware and at a certain
point in time there's gonna be a limit
to where we can you know think and
process information do you think there's
gonna be a point in AI where they reach
an equivalent level with us are they
gonna pass us or what's gonna happen
from this it's funny that I disagree
with your question because I think of us
as software right what's the most
important thing about you is your brain
and your brain I mean I hope it's your
brain and right the ability to ask the
question that you had ponder things and
so forth that's the thing that
distinguishes us from other mammals and
creatures on there on the earth well I
think of I I get to say what I think I
because I'm thinking right I'm software
right now it's absolutely true that
software is implemented by computer
registers and clocks and so forth and in
our brain it's done by 10 billion neural
connections which are quote hardware but
to me that's at the moment is expressed
as software so I think what you were
asking was given that in your framing
we're hardware and the software can
catch up how far does it get that's
roughly a question here is that fair so
I'll give you an example of a way to
think about it
so this lady over here she has a
self-driving car and she's teaching it
she turns teaches it to turn left this
gentleman over here has a self-driving
car and he turned teaches it to turn
right so now we have a car that turns
left in a car that turns right that's
kind of a bummer right because you need
to be able to go with ways well the car
can exchange the knowledge in a way that
this gentleman and this lady cannot
mind-meld
so there is a difference in the kind of
software a I learning that might be
possible in the future it does not then
follow so that's pretty powerful idea it
does not then follow that the software
will have its ability to do volition
that it'll be able to ask existential
questions the kinds of things that you
and I routinely do like we debated
Hardware versus software it may be that
that there's a limit to what this
technology can do and it's drive cars
really really well right and that the
existential questions will be much much
harder we don't know yet I'm gonna
forsake asking my question because there
are so many interesting ones coming so I
think we can take about two more before
we have to wrap up
hi my name is moon de ser I am a
software engineer working on embedded
system and I use Java and Android my my
question is why didn't go go bye-bye Sun
Microsystems because at the time that
we've had at Oracle by both Sun
Microsystems and su Google on Java
so why didn't so the question was why
didn't go go by Sun Microsystems yes why
didn't you go had bought Sun
Microsystems Oracle would not have sued
yes Google over Java yeah that's a
that's a new question I haven't heard
that question the we did not win when
when Sun was in theory available we did
not foresee and do not first see
ourselves in the enterprise hardware
business which was where Sun was
strongest and that that's roughly the
reason and I know that because I work in
both companies so the rest is history
hi my name is Kevin Sperry I'm taking
the self-driving car nano degree and had
a question regarding way most sincere
technical advisor for alphabet way Moe
is in an a certain aspect one of the
biggest risks
bubala ii especially spin it out have it
be a sown company but how do you go to
market with a product like that and how
do you feel about how they will have to
support it once it's actually in
production and customer support and
things like that well I think way mo can
tell its its story today better than I
can the history who of course was
Sebastian started this off in what when
he created the Google X labs of course
now he's a founder of your company and I
don't think when we started we force saw
that it would end up being a uber like
service with Jaguar and Fiat which is
where we are today in Arizona I think we
knew that the technology would work
eventually but it took a long series of
steps to get to this point and I think
there's many more steps to come but I
think the basic premise that Sebastian
and Larry and Sergey had when they
started this was that self-driving cars
will save lives and I think it was true
and it is true and it will be true and
if you've if you know people who have
been killed in a car accident it's one
of the most horrific outcomes you could
imagine anything we can do to ameliorate
that the better we've been given a few
more minutes from production so we can
take more questions hi my name is Luis
I'm a real estate agent and one of the
biggest conversations that we always
have is will real estate agents be
obsolete because of AI and then the
second question if I could get a picture
with you after this so let's let's ask
the first question what do real estate
agents do you're a real estate agent you
help people find and you help them sell
your house now do you use a computer
today to find that house yeah so and you
write a little program and you say I
want this part you know and three
bedrooms and so forth and so on but
you're sitting there talking to them do
you seriously think at the end that
somebody's gonna buy based on a computer
saying you're gonna love this house in a
computer voice I just don't I mean maybe
I'm old school but I think that that the
house for most people is the most
significant purchase that they're gonna
make I think the real estate agents are
incredibly important as much as for
emotional support and the insight that
humans have that maybe eventually there
will be a I that's so good that it could
say well we know you like you know
houses with carports and we predict that
there will only be one carport ready in
the next year so you better buy this now
and I'm not conflicted because I'm not
being paid by my commission and the
customer is gonna say yeah yeah yeah I
mean it just doesn't make sense to me I
think that that sales aspects which are
essentially human right motivation and
charisma and leadership the things that
you're undoubtedly very good at they're
not gonna go away they become more
important when we talk about automation
in AI we don't talk about the skills
that you're describing we're talking
about the dredge work right not the fun
work if you're a real estate agent the
most fun is showing off houses that's
what you went into the field to do I
like this one I don't like this one this
is cheap this one is expensive that's
where you add your value that's not
going away yeah hi my name is and
risking Sun I started the AI no no III
my question is related to education like
right now like all over the world the
education system hasn't like evolved
much and there are a lot of problems and
like do you see Udacity replacing
universities and schools or how is it
gonna like education like evolve because
I'm actually doing a master's I'm taking
some courses and I actually think that
some courses in Udacity are even better
you know so but and I agree with that so
the first thing is I would rather have
you think of Udacity as a plus rather
- so you'd acity is a new way of
thinking about education but I don't
think it replaces universities it's not
gonna try to sort of have sophomores and
juniors living together in a coed dorm
you know and the drinking parties and so
forth and so on do all the other life
experiences that are represented by
college
we're graduate school for that matter I
think it's different and I think we want
more of it and as Udacity and other
companies like it prove new models of
Education I hope that the competition
will improve the incumbents I don't
think the incumbents suffer because of
the competition I think they become
stronger and God knows in the age of
information the age of intelligence that
we're going into we need more education
better education everybody needs to be
educated everywhere in the world not
just in the leading countries etc so the
final question hello my name is Britta
waddling I'm working for a business
publication is actually the biggest
business publication in Germany and
obviously nobody asked this question yet
so I have to ask the question about data
data protection we are a big crisis of
mistrust you know the whole discussion
on Facebook use a data advertising and
obviously Google is kind of involved in
you know the data and advertising
business as well so how do you look at
this crisis and how what does it mean
for Google well as you know in Germany
and in Europe there's the GDP are which
is being implemented and I think
addresses some of these concerns I don't
have anything particularly insightful to
say about the current uses we've argued
for a long time that we disclose what we
do with the data it's fully understood
etc etc and I'm pretty comfortable with
that so at least and I don't want to
copy comment about other companies and
their misuse of this information but for
us the simple answer is we care a great
deal about the data privacy of your
information it would really hurt our
company if it were leaked or misused we
give you the ability to delete that
information and indeed you can using
Chrome you can do anonymous browsing and
those kinds of things so we make it
pretty easy for you to both meet the
gdpr but
importantly protect and respect your own
data which is where we're focused so to
wrap it up Eric if you had one piece of
advice to give to all the Udacity
students worldwide what would it be be
curious and keep learning you said it
earlier when you talk about your
children right that their expectation is
continuous learning I am I am now
embarked on a new set of learnings in
new fields that I have been curious
about at my age for no good reason
except I think it's just the best use of
my time I think you all should do that
as well thank you Eric and give it up
for Eric Tripp thank you thank you thank
you
[Applause]